okay so uh welcome to week six your half
done with the course at this point so
give yourself a pat on the back today
we're going to be talking about paxos a
lot more before we dig into that though
I want to talk a little bit about what
the next few weeks will hold so here's
our schedule okay so today is a fourth
the assignment the the programming
assignment that came out last Friday is
programming assignment three so those of
you who were actually in the course as
opposed to just watching on twitch if
you haven't taken a look at the spec for
assignment three yet be sure to get
started early you have three weeks to do
this one but those three weeks are gonna
go by fast for one thing this is a tough
assignment and for another thing you
have some other things to be doing
during these three weeks as well in
addition to the rest of the
responsibilities in your life you have
other things to do for this class so we
have a couple of upcoming reading
assignments for next Monday a week from
today we have a reading assignment I'm
asking you to read the Dynamo paper so
this is a distributed systems paper came
out in 2007 a kind of a modern classic
and we're gonna be discussing it in
class and hitting the highlights but you
should also read it yourself as
preparation for class next Monday and
then for the Monday after that we have
another reading assignment the MapReduce
paper another modern classic have
distributed systems from the 2000s and
so that's again we're going to be
discussing the highlights in class but
you should read it for for class on
Monday the 18th so these are both
conference length papers so they'll take
a little time to do so
be sure to allocate time for that in
between working on assignment three
assignment three is going to be due on
the 22nd
right now this is scheduled as a hack
day which was something that was very
popular last quarter so I don't plan to
lecture that day so and this is intended
to give you a little bit more time to
work on the assignment but we'll see how
things go and if I can't get through all
the material in the the preceding
lectures then I might have to leak over
a little bit onto that day so we'll see
what happens there
I also want to share with you that we
have a couple of exciting guest speakers
coming up so we have a for one thing we
have a panel of recent graduates of this
course Emma go mich Lawrence Lawson
Victoria Tran and Pete Wilcox are all
going to be so they're all they all
graduated from UCSC last year and took
this course at some point during their
undergrad some of their them were also
course staff for me last year when I
taught this course and they're going to
be coming back to talk about their
experiences working with distributed
systems in their time since graduation
and then we have a couple of other guest
speakers on Wednesday the 27th Chris
Callahan is going to come talk to us so
Chris is a former Googler he also ran
his own online course on distributed
systems a free online course which you
can check out it distributed systems
course comm it's a much more practice
oriented course than this one it's this
one is more theoretically oriented so if
that's what you're interested in go take
a look at it so Chris actually I found
out about Chris because he recorded a
brief advertisement for this course on
his YouTube channel and that drove a lot
of traffic to this course so I asked him
if he in turn would be willing to come
talk to us I think right now he's going
to talk about blockchain consensus but
the topic is not set in stone yet so
we'll see so that'll be very exciting
and then our other guest speaker is
Chris and McKelvey she's a good friend
of mine has worked on a variety of
interesting things and she works for a
really cool organization called digital
democracy I think she's going to be
talking about peer-to-peer systems and
I'm excited about that because that's a
that's very interesting and important
but we don't really have time for in the
rest of the course so she's much more of
an expert on peer-to-peer systems I
think than I am so so she's a great
person to have talked about that so
that's what we have coming up somebody's
asking on slack why are there ads now on
Twitch I don't know so I I do not want
to subject you to ads so this is why you
have options for how how you watch the
course if you're enrolled in the course
you can watch on zoom' or you can watch
on Twitch they both have advantages or
disadvantages but I mean it's possible
that it's showing you ads because
because I'm I'm now a twitch affiliate
but I didn't press a button that said
show ads so I have no idea and I
certainly don't get paid for those ads
all right so the other thing I want to
do before I move on to talk about PAC
system more is so the exam as you know
the exam was last Wednesday we're
gradually grading the exam we're not
done grading it yet and we hope to be
done with grading it by by Wednesday
this week and so the way that we're
grading it is that the course staff is
splitting up the work but a single
person is doing all the grading of a
given question so it's not like we have
some of the exams done and other exams
not done rather each exam is part way
graded for the questions that we've
graded so far
much like Map Reduce actually when you
think about it but it's the the with the
with the looking at the exam already
that I've done is that I've realized
that there are a couple of questions
that people really struggled with and I
want to talk about those
so the chandi Lamport question so let's
talk about this briefly so this was a
question where we showed you this this
run of a buggy implementation of the
chandi lamport's
shot algorithm and the question was what
was the bug in the implementation of the
algorithm and and what went wrong as a
result of that bug so we told you we
gave you some hints here so he told you
so the the the solid lions here are
application messages the dotted lines
are are the marker messages sent by the
algorithm the ovals are the snapshots of
the processes state and the and process
tree was the initiator so at the point
where this snapshot was taken on process
2 only event II had happened process to
send its marker message out the marker
message got to process one process one
snapshot at its state when it got the
marker message and then it sent a marker
message back to process two those are
the only two processes participating so
there was nobody else to send marker
messages to and that was it so um what
was the mistake here what went wrong
well if you look at the marker message
that got sent from process 2 to process
1 notice how that marker message crosses
over the message that goes from event F
to event D so recall that with chandi
Lamport a property that has to be true
or an assumption rather that the chandi
Lamport algorithm makes an assumption
that the algorithm makes is that
channels are going to have FIFO behavior
so that assumption of FIFO behavior is
being violated here in that marker
message that's going from from p2 so
it's it as a result of this notice that
the marker message arrives on on p1
after event D here so many of you
identified that event D shouldn't be in
the snapshot right you noted that it's a
problem that event D is in the snapshot
because event F over here is not in the
snapshot
and it's not okay to have an event in
the snapshot if something that happened
before at it was there but some of you
interpreted this as meaning well F
should be in the snapshot so indeed it
would have been a correct snapshot had F
been in the snapshot but also the
snapshot was initiated up here before F
so it's okay that F is not in the
snapshot and the problem is not really
that F was not in the snapshot the
problem was the D was so this marker
message here should have landed up here
before event D and the snapshot of p1
should have been taken there so part of
the question was uh identifying that
there were there was a FIFO violation
here which violates an assumption that
Shandi Lamport makes that was the
mistake that that I made in my
implementation of this algorithm so the
premise here was that I made a mistake
in implementing this algorithm okay so
then why is it such a problem that event
D is included in this snapshot well so
some of you some of you mentioned that D
was in the snapshot but you didn't
mention why that was a problem the
reason why it's a problem is because for
a snapshot to correspond to what's
called a consistent cut it needs to be
the case that for every event that's in
the snapshot every event that happened
before it is also in the snapshot and
that's being violated if we include D in
the snapshot here because event of is
not in the snapshot well D is so yeah so
so part of the problem was identifying
the the the the violation of FIFO part
of the problem was noting that because
FIFO was violated this event D was
included in the snapshot when it
shouldn't have been and part of the
problem was explaining why it was a
problem to include D in the snapshot in
particular because that made the
snapshot not correspond to a consistent
cut so that was what we were looking for
there very few people got all three
parts of that a lot of people got one or
two parts of that and so I gave a great
deal of partial credit on this one so
that's what we were looking for on that
one
um after we finished grading the exam
I'll have a chance to talk a little bit
more about other questions that people
may have struggled with so I'll have to
save that for Wednesday because we're
not done grading the exam yet all right
and feel free to come talk to me if you
have questions about this okay so let's
go on to the the main topic for today
which is what we're coming back to paxos
so in lecture on Friday we began to talk
about paxos and this is the what the
picture that we ended up with at the end
of Friday so this is sort of like a this
is like Paxos the easy parts and today
we're going to be talking about paksas
the interesting parts so this is a very
simple run of Paxos we had one proposer
we have three acceptors and two learners
and the way that it worked was our
proposer
started out by sending this prepare
message to a majority of acceptors by
the way so there are three acceptors
here so majority would be two but it
would but a majority but three is also a
majority of three right so any majority
will do and it would have been fine for
p1 to send this message to all of the
acceptors as well in which case they
would hopefully all respond with a
promise now P one only has to send it to
a majority of acceptors for the
algorithm to be correct but it might be
pretty smart for process one to actually
send the message to all three of the
acceptors in the hope that even if a
message gets lost it'll still get to a
majority of them right
likewise when p1 hears back from the
acceptors with these promise messages it
doesn't have to hear from all of them it
only has to hear from majority of them
so if it does hear back from all three
of them
fine no problem as soon as it hears from
a majority its happy so it'll be
satisfied as soon as it hears from a
majority but if it hurts from all of
them that's not an issue
so it might be a good idea for p1 to
actually send the prepare message to all
the acceptors in the hope that even if a
message gets lost somewhere either on
the way to the acceptors or on the way
back from the acceptors we're still
going to get a majority and if it ends
up being more than a majority no problem
or or if it ends up being more than the
smallest majority no problem
likewise here so what happens here well
we send this message out with a proposal
number which is both unique and higher
than any proposal number that we've used
before we get a response back from all
the acceptors with that proposal number
now we can send a message that actually
has this value that we're proposing
which is distinct from the proposal
number so we send an accept message
again we have to send it to an a
majority of acceptors so here I only
sent it to two but I could have again
sent it to all three and then it would
have also been fine had this third one
sent back the accepted message so when I
speak of a majority do understand that
that means any majority it could be
everyone or it could be the smallest
majority or it could be anything in
between so if there were five acceptors
then it would have been okay to have
three four or five so that's that's one
thing that I went one subtlety that I
didn't discuss last time there were some
other subtleties that I also skipped
over so we left two asterisks two big
asterisks in our description of the
algorithm if you remember and what we do
in those cases actually more subtle than
what we talked about last time so we're
gonna go through the whole thing again
today filling in the asterisks and with
them filled in hopefully we'll that will
then be able to look at some more
interesting runs of Paxos including runs
that have more than one proposed
sir and I hope that this will also lead
us into a discussion of why Texas is not
guaranteed to terminate okay
so one thing that I want to point out
here which we started to talk about last
time is is that there are several
milestones in a run of paxos so let's
try to identify what those what those
milestones are um somebody just asked in
chat did she just draw an acceptor
sending a message to other acceptors so
okay I have two questions here one why
do you all talk about me in the third
person why don't you just ask did you
just draw but the other but the answer
to the question is no there's there's no
place where an acceptor is sending a
message to other acceptors okay so what
are the milestones in this run of taxes
um so the first milestone yeah right so
there's a lot of lines in this picture I
know it's hard it's gonna get worse
so we'll do our best if there were any
point when I wished that I had more than
one little eight-and-a-half by eleven
sheet of paper to teach this course
online it's when teaching Paxos
so these diagrams are gonna get messy
and I wish I had a gigantic blackboard
to draw them on all right so let's let's
look at what the milestones are the
first milestone comes when a majority of
acceptors have promised a particular
proposal number so that milestone in
this picture happens right here I'll
call it m one milestone one so milestone
one is a majority of acceptors have
promised a particular proposal number so
a promise of n means I'll ignore any
requests with a promise or excuse me I
will ignore any requests with a proposal
number lower than a so in particular
this means that the acceptors are never
going to accept a proposal numbered less
than it
that's milestone what the second
milestone is this point right here where
we said consensus is reached and that
happens when a majority of acceptors
send this accepted message for a
particular proposal number n and a
particular value at that point consensus
has been reached even though nobody
knows it yet so that's the point of
no-return other things may happen in the
algorithm somebody else might even
propose something else uh but no matter
what at that point sooner or later that
zero is going to be what you end up
having consensus on it might take a
while but you'll get there and then
finally we said there's a third
milestone which sort of happens
individually for every proposer or
learner so the third milestone is when a
proposer or learner gets an accepted
message from a majority of acceptors for
a particular n that's when they know
consensus has been reached on the values
so this right here is milestone three
for the proposer one because right here
is when they've reached when they've
gotten those accepted messages from a
majority learner one got them here
learner two got them here so that's
that's milestone three the point at
which these participants in the
algorithm know that consensus has been
reached so those are the milestones
milestone one a majority of acceptors
have promised a particular proposal
number milestone two consensus has been
reached milestone three individual
participants know that consensus has
been reached okay so that's Paxos that's
easy mode Paxos we're gonna write out in
detail the steps of the algorithm with
the asterisks that we put in last time
and then we're gonna fill in what goes
in place of those asterisks
okay so a run of taxes starts with a
proposer so we say when a proposer wants
to propose a value it sends prepare n to
a majority and recall that this could be
the smallest majority or it could be all
of them or it could be anything in
between so n has to be unique so nobody
else can send that particular proposal
number it must be unique and furthermore
it has to be higher than anything that
that particular proposal that particular
proposer has tried before
notice I say it has to be higher than
any proposal number that that proposer
has tried before it doesn't necessarily
have to be higher than any proposal
number in the whole system which is good
because if it did have to be higher than
any proposal number in the whole system
that would be an enormous pain in the
ass right because you would have to go
around to everybody and find out Oh what
was the last proposal number that you
used okay
don't use anymore I'm gonna use the next
higher one so that in a distributed
system that would be miserable and it's
it's a good thing we don't have to do
that instead it's just this local
property it just has to be higher than
any proposal number that that particular
proposer has tried before so if p1 cents
per pair 5 if there were another
proposer over here it would be perfectly
fine for that proposer to send prepare
for at that point uh it might not have
much luck doing so because by the time
that prepared for message gets over here
these acceptors might have already
promised 5 which would have met which
would mean that they would ignore the
prepare for but there's nothing that
says that proposer 2 if there were a
proposer 2 here couldn't send it prepare
for ok so that's what the proposer does
initially then we go over to the
acceptor
when an acceptor gets this prepare n
message it asks did I previously promise
to ignore requests with this proposal
number
you
so desks did I promise to ignore
requests with this proposal number if
the answer is yes then it ignores it if
no it replies to proposer with with
promise n which means I promise to
ignore requests with a proposal number
lower than it this was our first
asterisk so we'll come back to that for
now let's go back over to the proposer
so we've we've we've seen the the
initial message from the proposer to the
acceptors we've seen what happens when
the acceptor gets one of those and
replies with promise and back over to
the proposer
so we'll say when a proposer has
received promised messages from a
majority of acceptors for a particular n
it sends an accept message to a majority
of acceptors with that end and we're val
is the value that it wants to propose
this was our other asterisk so we'll
have to come back to that as well and
then finally back to the acceptor again
so when the acceptor gets one of these
accept and vowel messages
it asks did I previously promise to
ignore requests with this proposal
number and if yes it ignores it if no it
replies with accepted of the proposal
the proposal number and the value and
sends that to all the learners as well
so it's this four stage thing right back
to our first picture we've got messages
bouncing back and forth between the
proposer and the acceptors so the this
is a we could number these if we want to
one two and then here's the other page
three four
so we left two asterisks in here um to
understand why we need to add something
more to this algorithm let's take a look
at what would happen if we had more than
one proposer so we'll draw this picture
but just to make it a little bit easier
to read let's leave out the learners
we'll pretend they're there but getting
rid of them won't mess up anything in
this example and it'll make it a little
bit easier for us to draw okay so let's
say that we have a proposer and three
acceptors just like before and another
proposer okay so let's let's talk about
what would happen in a few situations
here so let's say again let's say that
the proposer one sent out a prepare
message with proposal number five
that we got the promises in response
and will say that our accept messages
went out here let's say the value that
we're trying to get consensus on now is
one so I haven't drawn any messages to
learn our learners but imagine that they
were there okay so first of all what
would happen if proposer two sent a
prepare for message to the two acceptors
and let's say that it lands right there
maybe it sent it to this one too it
doesn't really matter okay so what
happens on those acceptors when it gets
that prepared for message anyone want to
tell me
yeah somebody said reply with promise
for so let's let's take a look at what
the acceptor the rules for the acceptor
are so we say when an acceptor receives
a prepare in if it previously promised
to ignore requests with that proposal
number it ignores it so did it make that
promise well that's what this promise
message means right here
maybe I should fill this in here so when
the acceptor replies to the proposer
with promise n what that means is
I promise to ignore requests with a
proposal number lower than it
that's
Zen means so going back to our picture
at the point when this prepare for
message hits acceptor one it's already
set promise five which meant it's
already promised to ignore requests with
a proposal number lower than five so
it's just going to ignore this purport
this prepare for message same thing for
acceptor two it's already made a promise
to ignore any requests with a proposal
number lower than five so when it gets
the prepare for it'll just ignore it it
won't uh crash the system or anything
like that
it'll just ignore it now maybe a three
over here will uh will send back a
promise for because maybe a three hasn't
heard from anybody yet but there's no
way that pichu is going to hear back
from a majority of acceptors because
even if it hears back from a three with
a promise it's not going to hear back
from these two so it's not going to hear
back from a majority uh if a majority
have already promised a higher proposal
number so it'll sit here waiting p2 will
sit here waiting to hear from the
majority of acceptors and it won't so um
eventually it'll time out alright so
keep in mind that process two or
proposer two has no idea what's going on
with proposer one over here all it knows
is that it's sent a prepare for and that
it only heard back from one acceptor it
doesn't know why right it doesn't know
if that's because these acceptors over
here are just slow or what it doesn't
know that there was necessarily this
other thing being promised so what can
it do well it turns out that it's okay
always okay to just go ahead and send a
higher numb
prepare message as long as the proposal
number is unique you're okay
so here I'm assuming that p1 has to send
odd-numbered proposals and that p2 has
to send even-numbered proposals but you
could use any sort of scheme for this as
long as it ensures uniqueness okay so p2
is over here waiting to get promised for
messages from majority of acceptors and
maybe it gets one from acceptor 3 if it
happened to sent to acceptor 3 but it
doesn't get the majority that it needs
in order to do anything um so in
practice the way that this would work is
that the proposer has some kind of a
timeout if it sends a prepare message
and enough time goes by and it never
hears from a majority of acceptors
then it can send a higher numbered one
so let's say that after a while p2 s
timeout expires and it decides to send a
new prepare message prepare 6 so this
prepare 6 message goes out to let's say
all the acceptors
so what happens now have any of them
promised to ignore requests with a
proposal number of six sorry this
prepare six this should have gone here
have any of these acceptors promised to
ignore requests with a proposal number
of six no so they have to respond but
this is where that asterisks comes in
right we've already hit our second
milestone in our paxos run so right here
was milestone 2 right
this point at which a majority of
acceptors sent these accept messages
with a particular proposal number and a
particular value so consensus has been
reached
it's just that p2 didn't know it yet p2
is still out there trying to send new
proposal numbers so the acceptors are
now obligated to tell process two over
here that they already accepted a value
so we have to add something additional
to what we wrote down before so here's
what we said before when the acceptor
receives a prepare end message if it
previously promised to ignore requests
with a proposal number if yes it ignores
it if no we said it replies the proposer
with promise n but this is the part this
is the case that we have to fix because
this is the case where the acceptors
have already have already actually sent
those accepted messages so
of just replying to the proposer with
promise n we have to add something else
in here right here it asks have I
previously accepted anything
if the answer is no it hasn't previously
accepted anything then what we wrote up
here is still true it replies the
proposer with promise n so this is the
arrow that we follow I guess we go back
up here in case if the answer to that is
no but if the answer is yes it has
previously accepted something that it
has to tell the proposer that somehow so
it has to respond to the proposer with a
promise message but that promise message
has to tell it what the previous what
the hyatt what its highest previously
accepted proposal number and its
previously accepted proposal value were
so it puts something extra in the
promise message so it still does a
promise of n but then there's this extra
piece in the promise message where it's
a pair I'm going to call it n previous
and vowel previous where n previous is
the highest its highest previously
accepted proposal number and Vala
previous is the previously accepted
proposal value so this now this promise
message now has two pieces there's the N
which was what it got in the prepare and
then there's the previously accepted
proposal number and the value that went
with that went with that accepted thing
so a promise message only has this
additional component
only gets used if the acceptor has
previously accepted something so let's
see how this looks in our picture so
here was this prepare for a request this
one times out this new one gets sent so
a three what is a three respond with
well a three hasn't accepted anything
right so a three can just respond with
promise six right here there's nothing
stopping it from doing that what about a
1 and a 2 well they can respond with a
promise message but it has to have that
additional component so their messages
are going to look like this pom is 6 and
then that extra piece is going to look
like 5 1
all right I want to go back and look at
some of the messages that are or some of
the questions being asked in chat um so
one question was what happens if
duplicate prepare and messages are
received at an acceptor yeah okay so
maybe so
so do you mean from from a given
proposer yeah so so if two instances of
prepare five came here then then yeah
that proposer I guess it depends how its
implemented right if that if that
acceptor knows how to do some sort of
deduplication then maybe it would only
send it back one promise in any case it
doesn't matter if multiple promises of
the same proposal number come back from
the same acceptor because you know three
or four or five is as good as one p1 is
waiting to hear back from majority of
acceptors so it's not the message count
that it's waiting for it's waiting for
them to come back from distinct
acceptors and there's another question
what happens when a prepare n plus one
is received before the accept has been
handled okay so the question was what if
what if this prepare six message let's
say landed up here what if what if that
had happened
what if proposer two had sent and accept
or excuse me what if proposer two had
sent a prepare six message and it landed
up here on acceptor one acceptor one had
already promised five well which case is
that you can look at what we wrote down
when it receives a prepare it did I
previously promised to ignore requests
with this proposal number no it didn't
then we go here so have I previously
accepted anything no it hasn't so we go
back to this case it just replies with
with promise n so so yeah if that were
to happen if the if the prepare six
message had hit here
then a1 would then reply with promise
six and then you're probably correctly
anticipating one of the things that
could go wrong here
then when p1 tries to send these accept
messages they're going to get ignored so
if you're starting to wonder if this
causes if this could cause a case where
Paxos doesn't terminate you're right
okay so before oh by the way let's see
okay sorry I get a little confused when
I'm teaching packs is sometimes okay so
in this case here now p2 has gotten
promised messages from everybody for its
proposal number six right but only one
of them is promised six and the other
two have this extra information tagging
along which says okay I promise six but
by the way I already accepted proposal
number five with the value of one so
presumably we did that for some reason
right we're sending that information to
p2 because we want p2 to do something
with it so that brings us to our other
gap that we need to fill in in the
algorithm are other asterisk so let's
look at what the proposer is supposed to
do when it gets those promise messages
so that's this part of our algorithm so
before we said that when a proposer has
received promise messages from majority
of acceptors for a particular end it's
going to send out this accept end
message with the value that it wants to
propose how do you think that we're
going to have to tweak this part of the
protocol
so here again is our picture of our
example run here and this is the
situation that we're in we're proposer
to has sent out this prepare six and
it's gotten one promised six and then
two promised sixes that have this extra
information tagging along
so what do you think that the proposer
is going to have to do with that
information
hmm somebody just asked how does an
acceptor know that p2 doesn't know about
the reached consensus uh well how does
how do these how do the acceptors know
that p2 doesn't know about the reached
consensus well and if presumably if p2
knew then it wouldn't be sending out
this prepare message to propose
something new right but if it but if it
does know it's not a problem to tell it
again
okay so the proposer p2 here is going to
have to take into account somehow this
extra information that was included in
these promise messages in particular
what it has to do is look at these pairs
of a previous proposal number in a
previous value it's gonna look at
whichever proposal number is the highest
and then when it does a proposal later
on the value that it must propose has to
be the value that went with that highest
previously that highest previous
proposal number so in this case they
both happen to be the same right they
both happen to be five so essentially
we're saying here okay p2 um you can you
can propose a value but it has to be the
value that went with this previously
higher accepted proposal number that
we've just told you about
I find this funny actually this is an
aspect of Texas that I think it's funny
it's like okay like you can go ahead and
issue your own proposal with your own
proposal number if it makes you feel
better but you have to propose the thing
that was accepted before
okay so we're gonna revise the protocol
that the proposal fault that the
proposer follows right here where these
two asterisks are as follows so we said
when a proposer has received promise
messages from a majority of acceptors
for a particular n it sends this accept
message to majority of acceptors with
that particular N and where val is not
necessarily the value at once but where
val is chosen as follows
if the proposer has gotten any of these
pairs
it has to pick the value that went with
the highest previous proposal number
if it hasn't previously gotten any of
these n pre-file preparers then it can
pick anything at once
so in our picture we're running out of
room here so let's let's kind of zoom in
on this bottom right of the picture here
let's say we have a scenario like this
so we have a1 a2 a3 and p2 there was
some previous stuff that went on on
these processes which we won't draw so
p2 sent its prepare six
it got back a promise six from a three
and it got back promise six five one
from a two and A one okay
so P two can now send an except message
out and it could send to every acceptor
but it only has to send to a majority so
let's say it sends to a two and A three
and it's required to use this value one
because that's what it was told was was
previously accepted so it's sending its
accept message out with proposal number
six because that's the proposal number
that it was planning to use all along
but it has to now that it's actually
proposing a value the value has to
propose as one because it was told that
that was what was previously accepted so
it's still using its own proposal number
note that it didn't have to change its
proposal number to five or anything it's
sticking with it six it just had to make
sure that the value its proposing now is
the one that it heard about
okay so what do the acceptors do well
what does an acceptor do when it gets an
accept message what do our rules say
when an acceptor gets an accept message
it asks did I promise to ignore this
well did our acceptors previously
promise to ignore messages with a
proposal number of six no they didn't
all their interactions with p1 over here
had a proposal number of five so it
didn't previously promise to ignore
things with a proposal number of six so
it doesn't have to ignore anything
instead it can reply and accept um but
well it checks to see if it previously
promised to ignore requests with that
proposal number it did not so it replies
so notice that a three and a two have
the same behavior here even though a two
we're saying had these earlier
interactions with with with P one and A
three didn't um okay so notice that this
doesn't do anything to invalidate the
earlier consensus that was reached on
the value of one it has a higher
proposal number but the value is the
same so that's why we had to add this
extra subtlety to the behavior of the
proposers and the acceptors because we
needed to make sure that a previously
accepted value got repeated and
reinforced so a three for all it knows
it never saw any of these other promise
messages over here as far as a three
knows this value of one was Peters idea
all along so a three doesn't know that
this value of one came from originally
from from P one over here but that's
okay all right questions about this
so this is very complicated right and in
fact we're almost out of time
and I didn't even have time to do the
quiz question today so in the couple of
minutes that we have remaining I'm going
to switch over and do today's quiz
question I didn't even have time to
start to talk about some of the other
interesting aspects of past paxos so
we'll do those next time but let's do
our quiz
so here's today's quiz question
and I'll leave that open for a few
minutes after lecture officially ends so
there is a question on twitch what
happens if the accepted values are not
the same so you're gonna have to so go
okay so let's say that let's say that p1
is interacting with a1 and a2 and let's
say that there's another proposer over
here well if if a1 and a2 both accept
for a particular value and then another
proposer over here gets to the point
where where it's sending except messages
so keep in mind it has to go through the
sequence of prepare and promise first so
if it's then sending except messages
well if a value over here has already
been accepted then it's not going to be
able to hear back from a majority if
it's trying to get a different value
accept it so I urge you to go and try to
take the rules that I wrote down and and
try to demonstrate the the issue that
you're that you're imagining and
basically try to break the algorithm I
don't think you're going to be able to
alright we're out of time for today I'm
gonna leave the quiz open after lecture
is officially over because I opened it
up so late sorry about that but we're
done for today
and we're gonna come back next time and
talk about other aspects of Paxos and
hopefully we're going to get to that
question that we started to anticipate
today which is situations where this
algorithm doesn't terminate so see you
on Wednesday